cette nuit dans le quartier dollar à
batterie de saint-pierre-des-corps des
flammes ont dévoré la façade de cet
immeuble jusqu'au septième et dernier
étage les 92 occupants ont été évacuées
et prises en charge par la mairie le
bailleur ainsi que leurs voisins
réveillés par le bruit et la fumée
un élan de solidarité qui n'efface pas
le choc et c'est parfois c'est la vie
parce que quand c'est la première fois
que ça vous arrive après ça ne donne pas
du tout envie d'habiter dans le même
logement donc même si même si refaire
des travaux
même s'ils refont des travaux ça donne
pas envie a immédiatement dit rabbit et
puisque ça je pense que dans l'ensemble
des locataires c'est un créé un
traumatisme quand même s'ils descendent
yeux pour voir et c'est là que j'ai
récupéré ma des amis qu'on va si je
pouvais bercé leur enfant qu'ils ont
reçue c'est de dormir à la maison ce
qu'ils avaient très peur de ce qui s'est
bâti en fait dans le bâtiment aucun
blessé n'était à déplorer l'incendié
débuter aux alentours d'une heure 20 du
matin par l'embrasement d'une voiture au
pied de l'immeuble très appartements ont
été endommagés
lessard une vingtaine de personnes sans
trois tous ont été relogés les
enquêteurs privilégient la piste
criminelle
pourtant le maire refuse de parler de
problèmes de sécurité
selon elle ce quartier calme et le
dernier incendie de voiture date de
plusieurs années
est ce que c'est un acte de pur
vandalisme ce que c'est une commande
sept voiliers il ya tout un tout une
investigation avant de dire voilà ce que
vaut ce qu'il faut faire maintenant je
crois qu'il faut toujours analyser
diagnostiqué ce qui s'est passé pour
pouvoir prendre des dispositions par
rapport à la situation
malgré l'absence de caméras de
surveillance le maire espère que les
habitants qui ont vu quelque chose
parleront aux enquêteurs en attendant
éloigner les voitures des habitations
est une piste qu'elle compte étudier
avec le bailleur social